in the war in ukraine the country's
president says russia committed a
terrorist attack by destroying a mall
full of shoppers a missile hit the mall
in kramen's truck yesterday killing at
least 18 people and wounding many more
crews are pulling the wreckage apart
this morning to help rescue workers
search for more victims rami and asensio
is there at the scene raymie good
morning
good morning this charred building is
what's left of the amster shopping mall
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says it was absolutely a targeted attack
by russia against innocent civilians
thick smoke swirled from the shopping
complex monday afternoon a sign far and
wide that russian forces had struck
again
this is a dangerous situation get to the
shelter yelled this policewoman
while firefighters worked to put out the
inferno and bystanders put up the
injured into ambulances
others looked for the names of loved
ones on a list
at the hospital this injured man said he
saw lots of wounded people burned people
some covered in blood
his wife said the blast threw her into
the air
it's really scary i tell women who left
the country with their kids don't come
back
g7 leaders meeting in the german alps
said the attack was abominable and
promised nearly 30 billion dollars in
new aid for ukraine ukraine
president zelinski in a televised
address said the country needs more
modern and effective weapons
and that's to help shoot down incoming
missiles the front line is just about
125 miles east from here and it's more a
question of when not if russian rockets
will strike again
tony nocencio in ukraine for us raymie
thank you very much